- I thought that scientists
understood how explosions work.
Now, we're not going to
see big orange fireballs
going up into the sky.
I've done that before, I've
filmed with a pyrotechnician.
We added a load of fuel
to make the blast look
like a Hollywood explosion.
But that is not realistic.
Besides, these days
Hollywood, and scientists,
can simulate those sort of effects
near-perfectly in a computer.
I looked it up.
There are industry standard
ways of predicting blast waves.
They are very accurate...
once you're about half a meter away
and there's clear air in between,
which is good enough for most
people, 'cause let's face it,
if you're five centimeters
away from an explosion,
you've probably got bigger problems.
But it turns out that's big picture stuff.
Right at the start, in the detonation,
in the first few instants of an explosion
as all that energy is released,
that's where the simulations break down,
and solving that problem could save lives.
This bleak old World War II munitions site
is now a university test laboratory
and the research is close up.
So let's see a test.
- Explosions are very
difficult to measure.
We need something that's
going to be rugged
and strong enough to survive an explosion,
but we also need something
that's sensitive enough
to measure things that are changing
over millimeter length scales
and sub-microsecond timescales.
The rig that we're going to
be using today is called MaCE,
which stands for "Mechanisms
and Characterization of Explosions".
It's a bit of world-leading kit
where we can directly measure much closer
than anybody worldwide can do,
gigapascals worth of pressures,
and that's a very, very
complicated situation
which we can't necessarily
model or predict currently.
And we're going to use some
high speed video cameras
to film what's going on as well.
- If you hit a metal bar the right way,
it'll make a ringing sound,
basically a musical note.
That ringing is made by
the bar itself vibrating
as the force from that initial hit
bounces back and forth within the metal.
And the pitch of that note
is really easy to measure.
You just listen.
The work the researchers are doing here
is much more technical
and much more precise,
but it's kind of the same process.
- It's based on theory
by a British physicist
called Bertram Hopkinson,
109 years ago,
and it's only now that the
technology is catching up
where we can affix
very, very small strain gauges
and we've got data acquisition
systems that can sample it
at the required rates and
required frequencies.
The strain gauge is a tiny dot
that we mount on the outside
of Hopkinson pressure bars,
solid steel, one meter long,
four millimeter diameter.
And we fix this strain gauge 40mm
from the loaded face of the bar,
We sample it 5 million
times per second.
We're going to set the explosive
a little bit further
away from the surface,
so hopefully we can see the fireball
and the detonation
products start to expand.
That's going to set up a blast wave
that's going to propagate
through the bar as a stress wave.
So the strain gauge records
a change in voltage.
We can work out stress, which
we can work out the pressure
and the load on the end of the bar from.
And there's a whacking
great big steel plate
that just acts as a shield
and just deflects everything away.
So the pressure bars trap that pressure
and send it downwards,
and then the arrangement
of the MaCE rig that
we're building towards
is 37 of these measurement locations.
But today we've just got one!
Just to focus on what's happening
right in the most severe part.
- So I asked the researchers,
what's the use for this?
Their first answer was, well, for science,
and that's fair enough,
but there are practical applications.
To start with, if this works,
building things that resist explosions
will become a lot easier and cheaper.
- In the 80s and the 90s,
the big challenge was big truck bombs
with tonnes of explosives.
Nowadays, explosive attacks
are much more targeted.
They tend to be smaller devices,
and as a result,
they're located closer to the thing
that they want to damage.
So that's why we've looked
in this very extreme near-field setting.
We're going to be doing some tests today
with 100 grams of high explosive.
It's around about tennis ball sized.
There are a lot of secondary
reactions that go on.
It takes a while to develop,
at least on our time scales,
and there are ongoing chemical reactions.
And that offers up the really
interesting prospect of,
can we do something that's
going to mitigate them
or even turn them off?
Can we surround explosives in
a particular type of material
to manage those reactions?
Bombproof luggage containers
or storage containers on transport?
That's a potential thing that could
be done with this research.
- If we can understand
those first instants of an explosion,
then maybe we can help
keep it under control.
After all, this munitions
site is built to do that.
It was designed to contain
anything that goes wrong by brute force,
just using huge amounts of earth
and concrete bunkers.
So can that be done with
less materials and less cost?
We're about to take just one
step towards finding out.
[horn blaring]
- We've never been able
to observe these features before,
so we kind of don't know
what we don't know.
That's what the group looks at,
uncovering what we don't
know about explosions yet.
- All right, what have we got?
- So this is filmed at about
a quarter of a million frames per second.
- Wow, okay.
Wow.
You can see it bounce back!
- So it hits the surface.
And then as it goes back up,
see it reigniting.
All that hot gas is
getting churned back up
and it's mixing with the oxygen.
And that's giving that secondary kick
that we see at these
sorts of scale distances.
It's continually pushing
the end of that bar
and it's sending that information down
- Because it's not one hit.
It's a push that-
It feels like one hit.
- Exactly.
- But you are recording that so quickly
that what you're actually
getting is a push.
- Yep.
- Wow.
- Cool, isn't it?
- That's pretty cool.